[Music]  when those seats are filled and when the  lights go down there's that moment  suspended in time we're waiting for the  magic to begin  [Music]  they cut you all I need is a shot you  guys have made a piano player not in 30  years  here he is our choreographer sander  rains you missed the time I don't need  to see it again  I can do the turn fine  on audition for you show works of Delhi  we need a saws under dancers to start I  can't put that on the marquee okay  that's time to deal she'll be starring  in free dance I need you to help me with  her to make this show work  they're called backup dancers cuz  they're always one step behind the star  I need to show to be certain and lonely  brilliant I want that too she's  phenomenal what exactly is going on  between the of Xander so she bared her  soul out there for you today  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you're strong and you're very talented  prove yourself  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]